okay why don't we go ahead get started
on a welcome everyone to our department
of medical informatics and clinical
epidemiology Thursday conference and
this week we have out-of-town visitor
and
try to advertise a little more broadly
and I'm always glad when
I see faces that i don't recognize
so for those of you who don't know me my
name is Bill Hurst and I'm not chair
deep mines
leme allergy and for the past couple
days we've had a visitor in town dr.
Howard Silverman well introduced in a
moment who is who shares with the number
of us a great interest in how you teach
informatics to clinicians which is
something that many of us who are
professionals and informatics even if
we're not necessarily physicians will
teach and of course there are other
clinicians besides physicians that need
to know how to learn
need to learn informatics and the tools
particular electronic health records and
Howard at his department his group at
the University of Arizona
among the leaders in this area we also
have some visitors from I won't mention
the city as they played in a basketball
game last night who are also here and
visiting with some other folks this is a
big week for informatics instruction for
medical students anyways let me briefly
introduce Howard and that don't want to
kick into his time too much so one thing
I do want to ask people for those of you
who are not familiar with this room when
you ask a question you need to hold down
the little button on the microphone in
front of you mainly so the people who
are listening to the recording work
since we also stream these things so
there could be millions of people out
there in cyberspace watching this we
actually do get a decent audience some
so they can hear the question although
Howard will paraphrase it anyways um so
Howard is a professor and chair of the
department of biomedical informatics at
the University of Arizona College of
Medicine in Phoenix where he's also
professor in the purpose of Family and
Community Medicine and bioethics and
medical humanism
previously he was associate dean for
information resources and technology at
the University of Arizona College of
Medicine he also has some previous
experience system director of medical
informatics Ian clinico clinical
innovation and banner health howard
graduated Phi Beta Kappa from Purdue
University majoring in mathematics and
German and then he earned a master's
degree in computer science from
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
where he specialized in artificial
intelligence applications and medical
decision making he then went to medical
school at Stanford University School of
Medicine and did a residency and family
practice at Good Samaritan Medical
Center in Phoenix so I will let
everybody welcome thanks for coming I
want to invite you to you know keep this
interactive as possible i have done this
more of a lecture than an interactive
session but please interrupt me as we go
along if you have comments or questions
custom Oni challenges and hopefully it
will be of some interest to see how what
would fully experienced over the last
couple of years also I want to just shut
for the shout out to dr. tysinger who 20
years ago is my instructor in pedagogy
so we're going to sis like my final exam
you know you're going to see if I
learned anything ok so it's nice to have
all of you guys
look forward to your comments and input
so I have to figure out how to position
there we go okay so this is the purpose
of the talk you know maybe we should
write that spot down the idea is you
know like we've had for various reasons
serendipitous and otherwise a whole lot
of experience now trying to figure out
how to teach medical students biomedical
informatics so i'm not sure we know
where the spot is exactly but we at
least know where the woolly mammoth is
and that's what I'm hoping to transmit
today so degree okay so I wanted to give
you a sense of just very briefly sense
of context so we are relatively new
four-year campus that grew out of a
regional campus in Phoenix so the
College of Medicine in Tucson accredited
in 1967 has been sending there about 40
of their third and fourth-year students
for their entire third and fourth years
in Phoenix years for 20 years because we
have a gazonga huge amount of hospitals
in Phoenix big big town
very high quality community-based
residency programs which those students
rotate along with
physicians in the community as
appropriate so we were started as a kind
of I would say a partnership some people
called it a shotgun marriage between two
state universities that were traditional
competitors and the way the marriage
worked was that Arizona State University
which was located in phoenix and is a
big University was given funds to start
something that would be relevant for the
new medical school Michael krob is the
president met University worked at
Columbia with Ted short-lived grandpa
when the grandpa's of Informatics he
understood the importance of biomedical
informatics he had a strong computer
science and engineering department so
they created a new biomedical
informatics department and I was
involved 50-50 on medical school side
and this new department a new department
setting up very much like the department
here to grant master's degree program
phd's the idea is the faculty then would
teach informatics to the medical
students so that was kind of a context
the new curriculum involved for sanction
themes which meant that we had rights to
claim time and a reasonable and
civilized way throughout all elements of
the curriculum which we have done and
these were the for informatics along
with ethics public health and behavioral
sciences so this put informatics on the
map you know we started our curriculum
we started with a blank piece of paper
it's just a whole lot easier to work in
these kinds of new materials in that
context I know I was involved yesterday
with dr. Korman you guys are doing
curricular Reformation so hopefully some
of this input can be used as part of
that effort
the LCM II did not like this model they
started out saying yeah the new medical
schools that are pal forming the United
States should be kind of tagged along
with some sort of parent campus and
that's how we started under a joint
accreditation they realized that model
doesn't work because you never keep the
two campuses equivalent so they asked us
actually to apply for separate
accreditation which we did and received
in last summer so our 80 students that
came in last summer are on a new
curriculum so we have done to complete
new curriculums in seven years and we
now have two medical schools that are
running as the second year students work
their way out through the pipeline right
so
it's been interesting
okay this is impossible to read but I
just want to give you that visual so
that basically the one the major
features of the new curriculum is
student start clerkships in early April
instead of summer that was one of the
purposes but it has implications because
it means the basic science has to be a
crust now there is going to be at least
we hear that there's a unicorn who's
going to write in with a little this on
the point of this of its horn but you
know we're looking to populate some
basic science into the clinical year
it's not clear how that's going to
happen because currently the students at
the advancing edge of the students is
just in the first year now this has
implications for informatics in the
curriculum because of this accelerated
basic science basically the criteria is
if it's on step one we need to teach it
in a pre clerkship that's a pretty
narrow criteria i think it's not that
strict obviously we need to teach other
things for clinical
page communication of the things
but we've argued successfully that the
criteria should be it's on step one
where they need it before they start
clerkships and we have a pretty good
case to justify the need for certain
aspects of Informatics training before
they start clerkship however it's not
there are no informatics questions on
the boards and if I had a magic wand it
could do one thing to change the
landscape I put informatics on boards
because that would give every single
medical school a chance to populate that
material somewhere presumably basic
science in appropriate ways
ok so I think this group I don't have to
go over these points too much why
biomedical informatics it's just it's
happening right and everybody in I don't
know we were talking about this last
night used to be that they'd say what is
that again now people know what it is
they know that they're producing wads of
data they don't know what to do with
they know they need clinical decision
support they are getting more
accountability for safety and quality of
the care rendered etc etc etc so I don't
think I don't think use case or the
pitching biomedical informatics is
nearly as hard as it used to be the
question facing me was how do i create
this curriculum when it
so I figured I'd call some of these
already doing it find out what they're
doing turn out there wasn't anybody I
couldn't find anybody anywhere if you
ask actually there are surveys of
medical schools in a substantial portion
report teaching biomedical informatics
but when you ask them what are you
teaching it's pubmed searching which is
important part of information literacy
but that's not biomedical right partner
so we kind of had them make it up
from scratch
okay so here's here's kind of the
historically what we did we took oh yeah
so we published a complete description
of what I'm telling you now in academic
medicine I'll give you the reference we
made sure that people understood VMI is
not the same thing as information
literacy and in fact in our school we
formulated information literacy
objectives and packaged those and we
have an interdisciplinary group that
teaches though so we have public health
people we have tisha the librarians
um
as I said we were unable to identify any
curriculum requirements to the nbme or
anywhere else so that was good and bad
right it was great because we could
teach whatever we wanted it call it
informatics but a little troubling
because we had no anchor if you're
teaching physiology you go out to nvme
you see the list of what you got to
teach zippity food out of your halfway
home
okay so not included on nvme they'll see
me has no standard speculated
informatics they have some about
information literacy but that's not it I
couldn't find anybody else that offered
content other than information literacy
as I said so
what do you do suggestions
wing it
can be more specific
I'm curious I mean I don't expect you're
not curricular designers that's not your
thing but how would you have what
everybody thought how would you approach
it
integrate use of informatics tools as
part of other curriculum items good so
this is always described as dishes to
copy in the class right instead of
asking for a separate class of water you
just put your cot in the class and just
take up that much space
go out and figure out what problems are
new doctors like dr. than Tina for
entering profession facing due to the
lack of biomedical informatics knowledge
you know what specific things I think
he's know how to do that they aren't
able to do or they have problems with
doing and figure out how to put that in
the curriculum right so going out doing
some kind of needs assessment
both real-time in medical school but
targeting their practice lifestyle
okay and those are great suggestions and
we we did that but we also started with
one of the thing we looked around for
any kind of standards we could find as I
said there were not in the traditional
medical school arenas but there was one
document that actually is quite good
which was the 1998 medical student
outcomes project so the WMC created
learning objectives and implementation
strategies for a variety of different
areas and they had done this in
informatics oh we're in 2004-2005 or 57
years old in the land of informatics
with a long time especially during that
period technology and techniques have
change we looked at that and actually as
we revise that I had anticipated we
might do like a wholesale revision it
really was about 80% of it was still
highly relevant there wasn't much about
mobile computing we added that point of
care decision-making stuff like that but
it was actually very good so we looked
through that we developed our learning
objectives what would now might be
called competencies and we also looked
at the core competencies that the ainia
had put out and we did turn of a
crosswalk just to see are there any big
gaps just it was the best calibration
check we could think of we kind of
tweaked it a little bit more and came up
with essentially a list of
objectives but as you know learning
objectives not the same thing as an
interaction with a student benefit like
that's that's the maybe the what the
aspirational what we had to figure out
how there's another problem with medical
students that's why i was wondering
there any medical students in the crowd
but for better and for worse medical
students have a binary sort on what's
important it's on the boards it's
important if it's not I don't care I
mean it's really very very amazing and
some of the more mature ones do realize
that there's something after step one
called clerkships residency a career in
medicine right but that's like yeah but
they also know that you know they're not
going to get the great residency if they
don't do well on step one so there's a
lot of pressure on them about that so we
also had to kind of figure out how to
motivate them to think that this would
work well
okay so we took those learning
objectives we map those two are
institutional program objectives we
decided to cluster them into topics and
I actually use Ted shortlists look to do
that because he has kind of a nice
taxonomy and chapters in the book is as
good as anything we could find us an
organizer then we had to lay out the
teaching sessions across all four years
where we actually specifically where are
we going to teach what and how many
hours of interviews reach top it so this
you can't read but this is just a page
out of that list of learning objectives
this happens to be informatics
competencies it shows
and you'll see you know kind of very
familiar things a lot of this came out
of the end that's okay so now we have a
foundational document where we could say
here's what informatics is that was
important to communicate to other
faculty and obviously start to build
educational machinery for the students
this was the topic list which was quite
long way this was way overkill is is
this a really complicated way to do it
but we had some time on our and since it
was an unknown space we wanted to be
recently rigorous but it's easy to
simplify but but generally seems that's
how that work that diverges and then it
converges
okay then
we went through and we took all of the
sections the specific topics learning
objectives key to that list you just saw
and specifically where it was going to
be taught knowing the sequencing of
these blocks that showed you that color
diagram though their system block I know
that the M bill d block comes right
before the neurologic science block so
as I signed topics I sequence the
instruction addition to make sure that
everything
and
the question was how much time do we
need for each of these and so Doug Fritz
man who at that time was at psu md PhD
who many of you know fabulous guy
we actually sat down at Stony Nick
that's this earlier we sat down for half
an hour break during when to Amy a
meetings and we just arbitrarily
assigned all these hours we're curious
are we going to have 500 hours are we
going to have four hours I mean we
needed to calibrate we wound up with
ninety three hours that we thought
ideally would work we in the long run
now currently have about 45 50 hours
which is probably about right
and as you were saying we're trying to
fall or somebody dimensions we're trying
to fold stuff into existing curricular
elements which I'll talk about with it
so that we're not actually needing more
time just need to be more clever
okay so this was pretty complicated
so then it came to the motivation part
of the students right how do we how many
motivate the students and so I put the
slide up at my intro talk to them
basically to say this is not what we're
doing you know this is every physicians
nightmare guidelines and all that kind
of stuff you're going to clinical
decision support is going to auto manage
my patients we're not trying to do that
what we what we keep saying them over
and over and over is what we're trying
to do is to enable informed automation
things like clinical decision support to
decrease the cognitive load on a
physician or clinician they have time to
attend to the human things that we do
uniquely well which is complex decision
making communication all that kind of
stuff
that's the goal also to respond to this
growing movement to share data to be
able to share data understand how to do
that exceptionally you know share data
with others as you would have them share
with you golden rule of data if you will
and ultimately really what it's about is
quality safety and efficiency right so
what we're in the end we're not
interested in teaching you stuff because
it's something that we like to talk
about it we're interested in having you
in a position where you can help ensure
that patients are not killed for the
long
which happens if we know the United
States
think about for lack of a better word
so just perforates would we mark it as a
new special situation because the new
clinical sub-specialty i prom eyes it
didn't exist in 2005
so we would tow students about careers
and informatics like types of things
that clinicians could be involved in and
some are really interested the new
clinical sub specialty is probably not a
validator for students of this content
but for those who are interested it's a
much more defined career trajectory and
it was a big investment for students to
do what your joy fair medical student to
take three to five years to go do
masters or PhD
informatics is a big opportunity costs
for them as the racking up
to the presence of the clinical sub
specialty in many ways allows them to to
make that decision later and to actually
at least get some kind of salary while
they're doing
but at the time it was
and frankly there weren't a lot of
formally trained clinical increment
itions around their round but a lot of
people were you know docks that were on
the job
that's a thought
ok
so what happened was we then about two
years after we launched this at 2007
around two thousand nine ish we
basically needed to review every aspect
of the curriculum I have brand new
medical school brand new curriculum we
went through a methodical rigorous
evaluation the curriculum and we
wondered how is this been received and
especially the people are not into it
you know the people are into it's easy
to could it sound
and we continue to struggle with how do
we make the value case because none of
our sessions are mandatory well very few
are mandatory there are some that
usually about labs or external speakers
or whatever so is some cases you know
students just didn't show up and the
students are medical student probably
all students are very clever they figure
out I can miss you know if I'm in my
block that's nine weeks long and there
are six sessions and informatics I can
get all those questions wrong I'm still
going to pat's my man so there's not
really a negative content direct
negative
so it's a tough one
and what's the quarter focus of the
instruction based on that who should
teach it at how so these were questions
we continue to struggle that this is an
iterative process we had made some
progress but we continue to struggle
with it
okay so before I get into this so the
other thing that happened was we
arbitrarily put in addition to the
informatics sessions that were peppered
through all the first three years we
also had two blocks which were in our
case one week blocked which meant you
got it great for that as a course if you
failed that there were big implications
and we could completely control the 19
hours of instructional time during those
weeks it was essentially like a deep
dive into informatics the initial blocks
were placed at the beginning of each
year the amount of thought that went
into that was the big zero or so we'll
put it in the beginning of the year
right that will start up up right so
what happened was the students come in
they're just ready to go right they've
been waiting for how many thousands of
years get the medical school first week
is prologue it's kind of you know
getting to know you kind of thing where
they learn the systems like I stuff then
they hit biomedical informatics and
there's this big thudding sound now now
the good news is students in the second
week in medical school are so pumped up
on adrenaline that does your life so
they're totally they were showing up a
little bit but it was obvious that it
was obviously this wasn't a good thing
right and we at the time we didn't
really have much content we were kind of
what is this whole thing
mobile skills you know we could quite
accurate decision because they're going
on
but more importantly there was a problem
with assessment because in a one-week
block it's really hard I mean the
students get like I said it great and if
you fail to portions in medical school
you're out so if they failed that one we
block is the equivalent of failing at
twelve o'clock and it really just wasn't
right so eventually part of the redesign
was getting rid of the short
just not because they didn't want
informatics it was just that sense of
the difficulties in assessment and
evaluation of it such a short block the
content was preserved but we did
redesign it substantially so really we
wanted to do redesign that was time
neutral
and the field is definitely changing so
we're continuously revising new tools
are coming online both educational tools
clinical tools and romantic
and again you know mindful of this goal
I mentioned earlier about quality safety
and efficiency so we while we wanted
them expose them to all of the four sub
disciplines of informatics and we do so
they do sessions on bioinformatics a few
sessions on the imaging
population informatics largely as you
can imagine we're really interested in
clinical
and we really are increasingly
interested in skill acquisition
particularly use of the EHR which we're
talking
college in San Antonio so
that's been some of the shift in the
curriculum
ok so now what I'm going to talk about
you know I'm going to get into this
redesign so we wanted a hands-on
rather than talking about EHRs one of
the students using hrs on the EHR side
and we needed to figure out how do we
develop assessment methods and how do we
hybridize with other curricular elements
this is the Cochrane that's right how do
we use what's already going on and
insert ourselves into a useful way
we just had a new building built we had
we have gorgeous learning studios
describing yesterday these are big rooms
with well there's three vets eat 60 and
one that seeks 140 so picture a room
like this with five tables on each side
and LCD screen at each table so that the
tables can do table exercises and then
those screens can be slaved to a laptop
at the table or to the instructor PC or
any of those screens can be broadcast
all the other screen so this opens up
the opportunity to do some interesting
labs
we wanted to leverage that space
we really want to put content in the
clinical years but there's problem which
is that you have to do at seven times we
have seven rotational cycles in a
clinical year so if you're going to
insert something better have faculty
you're willing to do it seven times per
year
not insurmountable but also the
clerkships themselves have huge amounts
of stuff that they're trying to cover so
that it's actually a lot harder to get
new content in there unless it serve
their trip so that's tricky everywhere
we want to expand use a community-based
faculty which the presence of the
department now is really greatly helping
but bringing folks
there are huge healthcare systems and
Phoenix is the Phoenix VA which you're
all hearing about in the news
actually I ask my colleagues there if
they found the list they said they're
still looking for that there's they
can't find the list
so the Phoenix VA banner help which has
25 hospitals dignity health site key
operations is centered in Phoenix they
have 43 hospitals we're talking about
like hundreds of hospitals and
implementations of all stripes that are
working we need to bring those people
and we really want to move more into
what is a very rapidly growing field of
consumer health informatics mph ours as
well as all the big data big data mining
all I know stuff now that may or may not
be useful for the medical student that
as
campus that that's a big interest
now what we did we have a curricular
tagging system so we have to librarians
that go through every single teaching
session apply a set of tags we expected
with you MLS tag we decided we like we
actually created our own tagging system
in and largely this is for curriculum
accreditation purposes so these tags
were selected because there is some
specific LCD standard that says tell us
where you teach about X
what was surprising to me was I went
through and tagged just pull biomedical
informatics and a lot of these sessions
I have no idea what they're teaching so
this now works both ways right we're
trying to get curricular time but the
other really critical thing is we want
to be sure that other faculty are not
teaching informatics covertly and I
don't mean that in a negative way you
know I mean but that they're not and we
found this frequently that they would
put out a session and it would have
something traumatic content might or
might not be properly sequence might or
may not be accurate
etc and usually XX it usually always
when we approach them and say so you
know we look at the PowerPoint could say
would you like little help with this
they say yeah absolutely I know what I'm
doing you know so it's a friendly
conversation so this is what we call it
kind of scope creep where the theme
directors would meet with the blog
directors at course directors to get our
material into their blocks properly
contextualized but also to find out what
else they're doing that might be
followed this was actually much more
prevalent as you might imagine public
health
I don't know culturing and laboratory
diagnosis of bacteria I don't know
so so this is another important thing as
you guys undergo the curriculum reform
or in any other school as well to have
some reasonable checks and balances
about other people that are not
necessarily back
so it's not unique general
this is a list of what we came up with
for the well i would call now old
curriculum this is last year that was
actually as you can see kind of a
four-year thing the let me translate a
little bit transitions is a two-week
block between basic science clerkships
intercessions our one week usually one
or two week blocks in the clinical years
where they have the ability to come back
to campus as a group and be taught
clinically relevant basic science
which includes so we have time there we
do a fair amount of safety and quality
stuff there
we've developed an interesting
prescription writing workshop in using
epic with pharmacy students where the
students are prescribing but they have
us senior pharmacy students are
we don't figure out what to do it
it's been very interesting
okay so let me pause for a second before
i get to version 33 point 0 which is now
where we're going in the new curriculum
and this is there's a lot of painting
wires here we're still thinking about
but i just want to pause for a second
kind of trap any comments and questions
yeah so
we've had this discussion but the
interested in sharing with the group you
know we we've been trying to do this at
Hsu I was put on the curriculum
committee in the mid-1990s by the Dean
saying do this and and the response I
got from most the faculty was the other
stuff is important but not in my course
or not in my clerkship and actually the
one good outcome is that we turned our
attention to graduate education and
developed our program here so the world
might have been different if we had been
successful but I'm curious what kind of
reception you got what you know what the
politics was and whether maybe you've
seen a change over the years which I
think we're seeing a change here now
yeah it's definitely i mentioned earlier
it's definitely people are more more
interested in informatics and i are
getting a sense for its role in health
care we were lucky I mean I I was like
because even though I wandered into a
situation where I didn't know what in
the world I would do
it was a new medical school so there was
there was no I didn't have to take hours
from somebody to teach my stuff so
that's a unique circumstance that you
get maybe if you
lifetime but the other thing though
frankly is our Dean was a rabbit
supporter of
and maybe Rapids a little too strong but
a strong supporter right he wasn't
actually but and and I don't know why
because not infer magician he's a
pathologist he has no particular
knowledge of Informatics but he's a
forward-thinking guy and I he he attends
every single applicant orientation so
when applicants come to campus for their
interviews he does a one-hour stick like
welcome to campus here's our campus and
it covers all this stuff but when it
gets to those themes in the curriculum
and I've heard them say that's on
numerous occasions will save the
applicants so if I OU Medical
Informatics i'm not sure what it is
fellow guarantee you it's getting more
important than your stethoscope in your
practice lifetime so that's you know
so when you when you have the seven at
the top that's really helpful it's not
not going to do everything right but
still faculty to work
it sure helps a lot to have high-level
kind of support but I think also because
we were you know again unique
circumstances we were small the faculty
was relatively small
there was a lot more you know barn
building kind of feeling and people we
would and the other thing is that we
often would help them do things that
they couldn't figure out how to do in
their locks so what happened when the
theme directors would meet with the
block director we would get into some
really creative examples of how we might
take a topic that they need to teach or
one to teach
and just kind of twist a little bit so
it might be more interactive
one of the things that happened for
example as we do these case cases every
week and by the end of the first year
the students have game fists they know
that that you know all they need to
harvest out of that opening activity is
learning objectives so they're very
devious and efficient at milking those
learning objectives out of the
facilitator and by second year it's kind
of a joke just like why don't you just
give it to us or wasting two hours on it
so you know what we're proposing we did
a pilot with when the block directors
where we put the case into the EHR a lot
like France doing
and put a little spin on it where the
students had to go into the HR to get
the case information instead of on a
PowerPoint students kind of got really
interested all of a sudden so you know
looking for those kinds of opportunities
to not compete for time but actually
work together collaboratively take this
up to another level in terms of learning
that was another thing that really
worked well
harder to figure out where those are but
when you get the conversation started
I thanks for this Howard I've got an
implementation question now you
mentioned teaching stuff too early
before there
had that experience the first couple
weeks said why your country is so the
issue is have you had experienced you
gave a few on whether to sort of plant
the seed like you're going to be seeing
this later and
do versus just leaving along
yeah a really good question because
hotter the way always kind of joke about
is you could prepare steak really well
but give it to one month old baby
you know it's not really they're not
going to really like it that much Tino
got ft so so that was in addition to the
motivation question the idea of how
should this sequence and at what point
at what point it's a developmental thing
for medical students as they go through
the four years right so at what point do
you give them one and then how do you
sequence all that so initially we
sequenced it largely based on the blocks
so if we were in neurologic Sciences
we're trying to think about who we
talked about neural nets or something
like that that absolutely didn't work
so when we redid this in nineteen
whatever was
I'm sorry about 2008 2009
what we did is we basically if you're
not here who secures the
universe of what we want to teach them
about informatics and here's how it
should be sequenced from an informatics
point of view what makes sense so it
lets just take it at a great a highly
you know high level non granular level
we want to teach him about data in our
first year because that cheese up the
conversation about decisions which we
teach them up in their second year in
clinical decision support and if you
understand about data you can understand
a little bit more about electronic
records right the big database etc so
there was a natural kind of sequencing
of informatics topic so we quit trying
to figure out how to link it all to the
blocks and we sequenced it in it to
address the question here you're talking
about start small then commitment and we
were listening to students and other
faculty and the other faculty came to
sit said you got to teach this earlier
because I teaching such-and-such would
be really helpful they had that
and that worked much better and then we
would bolt it to the block at some way
or another we would find a connection to
the block so as an example we're
teaching data we talked about this
yesterday a little bit we're teaching
the students what is the database what
is data was a data schema and of course
they're like but fortunately they all
have to do a required scholarly project
so in the back of their mind they know I
might get a data set I should probably
pay attention to this stuff
so we did that but we wanted to
contextualize it in a clinical context
so since that happened to fall in the
neurologic science block based on
sequencing we used a neurologic
tradition we use something to the doctor
so we just been actually been the block
director got really excited because
that's one less thing she has to work at
her lectures at suntec James students
learned it at a deep level not because
they had a couple lectures on
Huntington's because they had to learn
that like on the fly to get to the
schema formulation so on
so it's really tricky to figure out how
to secret I just can't
just no right way to do it so it's a
matter of experimentation it has also to
do with what your resources are where
your strengths are and what your vision
is about
we do want them to understand about data
and we want at the end the other thing
in addition to that non cookbook the
safety quality efficiency we want them
to be informed consumers
he products as quick as clinicians
they need to be able to feel like they
could talk with the developer in some
reasonably intelligent way to say i know
there's a better way to disease i know
there must be templates or i know there
must be a better point of to your
decision making
so so it is tough and you're right if
the sequencing is really important and
frankly this is an N equals one
experiment because no one I'm not aware
of any thought uncle waitress
there's no universal medical student
them and even if you establish the
competencies that still doesn't tell you
how to actually roll it out you know no
days it was program cooter screen called
program one program one say hello call
programmed to then all of a sudden it
was time for coffee breakfast I'm sure
we're going to do a program
so having that sequencing in mind as I
think helpful so like my feeling would
be for you as if our petitions to think
through especially those of you in
clinical background to think through the
blood and then think about the
sequencing which largely you've done in
a lot of you on my work and then then
figure out how to how to actually kind
of compile that on to the existing
curriculum
so it's not independent but it's
integrated into that mr. curriculum it
actually serves you
other comments
okay so i'll just tell you where we're
kind of going
and I want to credit soumya ponch nathon
who soon as a pediatrician who was
actually in the first group of students
that went through the ASU
BMI master's program by far my best
student and I was thrilled when she came
back around and said yeah I'd love to
help you teach the informatics
curriculum so she now is that tape
mistaken over the team director
last year too and it's really moving
this whole thing forward very rapidly so
I really have to give her a lot of
credit
okay so for those of you that you know
speak medical school or residency jargon
Franco oh yeah these are the
competencies actually foundational is
not but these are the six holy
competencies across all medical
education frankly extending in fact
and we've listed our wording of these
this is I think system based practice
so edgy otherwise let's let's now really
align the instruction with competencies
send me last night and then this is like
as I said wires hating kind of thought
piece so there's red is implemented and
green is like we're in the process of
redesigning so if you look at these
competencies I don't go through these
one by one and I'm happy that you know
about the PowerPoint but this basically
is how we're starting to think more and
more but one of the things you can
notice is in addition to the specific
competency actually the company so so
big big buckets these are probably a
little bit more of learning objectives
we're starting to lay them out where
they should where they should be HR boot
camp for example cce is clinical
continuity experience it starts in
August of their first year
we got feedback from the faculty in that
part of the curriculum that they wanted
the students PHR enabled before they
came to them so we do this now we teach
them significant EHR stuff
and it's actually worked out well
because that's when they're excited /
units so actually paying attention you
know before their attention span goes
them like that of a nap
so anyway what we've done is we've
layered these out into specific blocks
and then I can run through all these
this this one I have another slide after
this so one of the things that that
people here in San Antonio been working
on and I was surprised I thought we were
the only ones interested in it but it
turns out there's an explosion of well I
closer to the tiny guides are of
interest is this issue of teaching the
students the communication skills and
almost physical skills about how to use
electronic record
in room as a relationship enhancing tool
and so we've been doing a lot of work on
as a valuable object to communicate with
patient not just in that clinical sense
but in the relationship sense but it's
not going to slide of this study we did
where we
took existing sessions that were in our
clinical skills curriculum where the
students every other week come in and
have to interview standard eight
patients and our assistant they're not
really great it because it's all
formative but there's a very granular
checklist that the attendings the
faculty check and the standardized
patients the actors were there seeing
how the communication checklist and
students themselves have checklist so
it's an ideal setting to gather data and
we brought in epic and put the patient's
data actually vital signs of meds only
to make it simple I just said to the
students you must check vital signs and
that's on the computer with
if part of your encounter and the dotted
line on the bottom that's all we said we
should have how to use epic we gave a
two hour epic initiation beginning of
their sessions we said remember vital
signs meds click click click here's how
you get sit down that's all we did and
the top salad bar where the group where
we gave them actual instruction about
how do you introduce the computer into
the encounter what do you say to the
patient how do you position yourself and
the computer relative to the patient how
do you signal when you're going to be
doing something that computer versus not
and so on so forth and these three rows
are standardized patients on the bottom
faculty and students and the first thing
that obviously pops out at you is a big
difference
that's p lesson play on
so there are three things that came out
of this study what is
I'm sure there no medical skids in the
crowd right the one is that digital
natives are not good at it so the fact
that they understand hunting and are
very comfortable using computers in no
way influenced their ability to do
anything that was communication and
hands
so we verified that this is a learned
skill secondly that's a second right you
see the improvement right so we verified
that with training which consisted of
three 15-minute sessions just prior to
them seeing the patients over these
doctor accession so we follow that down
to about 20 it takes about 20 minutes to
do this to produce this effect that's
the second
so this is an example of kind of things
a connection we did this we faculty
respectively had a big discussion about
whether it was ethical to have a control
group that was not getting the training
so we decided that epic approach this
was to Train everybody baseline on epic
so at least they had the navigation
skills but it's just like a new drug we
didn't thought of you know it could
equally be harmful we didn't know now
that we know that it works we have
really good data about that now it's
just standard
but run run
okay all right so you'll keep me honest
here if I'm exaggerating I'm not
actually i was a bit of cuz I'm not
criticizing medical student it's a it's
just the way it is
this is just out yesterday so it's
really proud of it you know so I just
could come
and moving along
can sqh our questions so
well actually this city is rapidly
becoming
vendor but that isn't always the case
and and of course even within that one
system you can have very different
screens and so forth did you did you
address the issue of you know kind of
what you would show them in the first
year and what systems might of course
the technology even itself may change by
the time they get
third-year fourth year in
yeah so it's a good it's a good question
we know that our students go to so many
hospitals that they're going exposed
almost every
certainly in Phoenix there are big
Cerner shops and big epic shop so we
know there can it goes to
some cases
so they do get that during the clerk
ships our problem is we just could get
access
and the reason we got access to the epic
training instance was the county
hospital with who we have an affiliation
did a big bang go live in her hospital
so they had seven training system that
were worrying and grinding 24-7 and once
they got past their big bang go live a
decommissioned those all but two for
maintenance and we were actually
assuming it was smart enough to say that
we have one of those by that you're in
the commissioner said sure so we also
magically had access to that and we're
in the midst of getting acts at the
sermon we think we need to have more
than one
but on the other hand and I have no
dated
validate this assumption I have this
feeling like I think we talked about to
say that like a car what's you you know
once you learn how to drive a car you
get into another car you know there's
got to be a steering wheel somewhere
it's
so like a stick once it's a little funky
so so it'd be ideal to have them exposed
to more than one system it's just that
the getting that arranged has been
logistical II difficult I think we're
well on the path to getting Cerner
which are give us some of us
in that picture it seem like most of the
things that you were that you were
describing the orientation were not like
this button is over here on that button
is over there except for this the same
thing that both groups God right most of
it was sort of soft skills about how to
use that accounts all about what kind of
meta way and i would i would expect a
lot of that support between hrs oh yeah
well you know the
the quality whatever that means of the
implementation clearly impacts your
ability to clinicians
but you know that it's like beauty it's
kind of hard you know when you see it
but the heart you know prospectively how
to manufacture it so there's no question
that some systems will produce
more lift than dragons on the other
but also it's fascinating as we've
rolled that training out to residents as
a grand rounds
is that we've done it with attending
physicians the same phenomenon occurs in
every group which is there's usually a
spectrum of comfort and capacity in the
group itself and so there's always one
person who says I do it all after my
shift because I know what happened
and then you have the other person that
says oh yeah well I just rig some
templates up i'm glad i get any person
so really we feel like our most
important contribution these trainings
is to have those people identify each
other and go off somewhere to get coffee
and talk usually there's intrinsic
expertise in the group is just not sure
one of the things we try to emphasize an
hour
one-on-one back session
is that if you can adapt these skills
now you might have the chance of having
a hobby in a life so that you're not
doing on your charge after work and so
the quality of life if you're able to
have the cotton and jar as opposed
absolutely and we all know that the
veracity the accuracy of clinical
charting at the end of shift when you've
seen it's been in your specialty maybe
20 patients pretty marginal now
obviously people take notes maybe
whatever they do
it's just not as good
Charlie plus you miss the advantage of
actually enhancing
where it's actually better than you're
doing paper right because you can swivel
thing around and show patients their
meds and say is this list correct or
they can show them their labs or an
x-ray
tap so patients really love it
mentioned a couple people at the last
phase of the study the standardized
patients were begging me to call their
physicians their personal physicians the
please instruct them as soon as possible
on
they said I know it's a fake encounter
with a medical student is great power
we've had the same result
the docs that they're working with or I
come up each r us how to do this
it's interesting actually we tell us to
please feel free to share this with your
preceptors Plus Dave's you know they're
went to see what other people are doing
it may kind of get the Delta you know
okay so this is just a lot actually put
this in here more just to kind of leave
it behind but more about
they're planning and professionalism
we're still working on
although we do we know we have talked
about
so there's a lot these are newer areas
that we're building out
so the idea is if you're in the creek
clerkship years we're no longer call you
Mears wanted to make no sense to say
that we're having to think about what
we're going to call him you will as well
I think we're calling a pre clerkship
years
what's that
let me go pre-clinical right
so we're really talking as I said
earlier about data
and these other areas by securities of
biomedical informatics are covered but
not necessarily in depth
you're too really looking a clinical
decision making
support so year too we retain the one
week block because it was its remains a
really cool block it's going to be now
merged with scotty project and it
capstone activity so it will actually
become part of a three-week plot which
actually it's kind of helpful but
briefly in that week what we do is we
get them for a whole week right so we
both the doors we on Monday really talk
about decision making and and we give
them a little quiz getting first thing
to get is a little quiz which is
anonymous and we give them a bunch of
clinical questions just answer these as
best you can of course it's a trick
right there's an a quiz and equip
and they're framed differently so we
elicit framing bias each and other
classic decision biases then as the day
progresses we've compiled their data we
talked about clinical decisions talk
about data
teristics bias talk where they actually
see the results of their their decisions
right because it's always the other guy
that makes the crappy decision never me
but it's usually pretty humbling for the
students when they realize they as a
group collectively have demonstrated
exactly the biases that are reported
lurcher Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday
are done in learning studios where we
give them we have fewer students we gave
them one clinical scenario now that
we're giving them five so we have 10
groups H students each
two groups each topic to the five topics
and they have to do using triage
software which is commercially available
decision analysis software often used
for finance they have to learn the use
of software which talked about a second
then they create decision analysis trees
for these different conditions they have
to determine terminal utilities and for
the terminal utilities that our cost
base it's real easy because it's like
okay we did this test we did this
treatment so that's this is the cost
they also have to do patient bait
terminal
which are different so from a patient's
perspective if i did a false negative on
h pylori test not going to get gastric
cancer what's the negative so
so it turns out that utility is quite
high even though it's a low probability
you know it starts to bubble through you
get it different you actually get
different often treats flip you get a
different recommendation you're looking
at patient ility so what do we do we
bring in the behavioral science person
right because we're doing this team
fusion
jazz things and she starts to then teach
them how do you interview patients to
elicit their value so that you could
better make decisions that are coherent
there
a lot of energy in the room students get
into it we actually as I mentioned could
come back to software we didn't want to
do this since offers had the treaty we
had them doing the trees just drawing
them out the first year because we
thought that software would get in the
way if you drag you know and in the
first year we had 24 students we had
four groups of six so I'm walking around
all the sudden I see one of the groups
is using triage and then I walked around
and I see all the crow tickets at triage
and it turned out one of the students
was a PhD were in use triage in his lab
so he started his group using it within
about a half an hour to spread to all
the other groups and they were already
self-trained and using it by the time we
figured out what was going on so we just
buy it might
so kudos to the students for teaching
so I've been getting into your three
looking at point of care decision
support we used to teach this early
terms of sequencing what we got feedback
is that the students in rather get that
kidneys epocrates I used I've met but I
want it when I get ready for clerkships
that we get into a little bit more depth
of Pretty Cure tool
specific tools ones that are licensed by
our university or our campus and that
pulse a little bit about how to assess
and evaluate those
quality issues i mentioned earlier we do
writer workshops in the fourth year
intersession so how do you prescribing
you want to get more into patient
portals and also big data predictive
modeling
no idea Big Data exchange that we always
hope
so we have five minutes left they'll be
happy to
questions comments
have you ever dragged back any of your
graduates
and we dragged back graduates no I would
love to track back graduates but our
oldest graduate is finishing present
so I would love to get him in about 5-10
years of even our practice in a while
but the problem with all of these this
is a joke that soumya and I have every
year is radically different especially
in the earlier because you're changing
it so you're always tweaking your stuff
if your care about teaching but the rate
of change in the first couple years of
significant I in my head had four
different sequences in informatics I'd
remember this class got this business
but not that I'd make sure I got that to
this class it's crazy and I had it in my
head and I could articulate it but
anybody else founded a bizarre
conversation so the problem is until we
never thought we could really a sense
long-range impact of the quick them
until it's stabilized and as you can see
it's continuing
it's kind of hard to know where the big
samples I think another aspect of that
maybe you could ask them sort of what
they are using
you may be able to ask that independent
of what the
right I would love to have that
opportunity
and I'm saying that because getting to
these people
and getting even when they were our
students got a questionnaire was quite
difficult in even when you bribe them
the variance way it's the only time
we've actually been able to get good
responses is where we lock
which is what we're doing now with some
of our students we have like once a
month is like assessment day we buy them
food and they have to stay for the full
hour complete
it's logistical challenge where it's a
great point it's a great point and I
always am aiming for 10 years from now
I'm aiming for that student to come back
to me and say that stuff that we thought
was I was saying I have had this happen
that stuff we thought was nonsense turns
out
that's why I'm hoping to hear
well generally nutrimetics i think it
was none slim I don't know if you have a
different perspective but not not very
well penetrated and relative to the HR
skills not I mean I've asked all over
Phoenix there is no shop that's teaching
relationship skill department basically
in charge
although i was asked by the LA Regional
Extension Center come out
and I generally don't like to do like
road shows but I was fascinated to see
if the methodology would work the
practicing physician / if it would be
and it was even more compelling for the
facts exhibition because they knew there
was problem in the way that they were
relating to patients with the HR but
they didn't know what to do about and
just like the residents I described
earlier there was someone that figured
out some really cool things to do here
someone I can't figure out all you guys
get together so so I think more of this
needs to you know be out there
for practicing physicians as well but
there is no real easy vehicle I mean you
have your courses here but that's a
heavy
and frankly even if we say 10 years no
it's going to be better i doubt it
unless more medical school
I just have a comment about you think
software
triage for a co cycle
and it's really interesting to see how
they react to this concept of
like and every year we do the course i
always think got it somewhere we can
incorporate this
once you had these students who started
using triage did you have trouble or
difficulties
sending the concept of using the
software to subsequent batches where you
well I guess who the triage expert is
which was let me tell you on the job
cheers learning so so we actually only
by a 30-day student license their $25
and after 30 days and sunsets it's done
I have had a couple students come back
who are doing it one particular between
scholarly project in a very clever way
wanted to use decision analysis
but one of the things we stress during
that Monday opening of that week is that
you're not going to use decision
analysis practice it's more likely if
you're in public health for your setting
policy guidelines
not going to run a decision
it's more of the concept that there are
structured ways to incorporate new
information into decision-making you
know so it may inform say a
evidence-based guideline or man for
it's going to be precious to you they're
actually
but it's intriguing for that because all
of a sudden they realize there is a
structured way that this is not just
such as such told me I should
the other thing is it's a really good
refresher for
sensitivity
goodbye to table they have to really
understand that
if there's some ancillary benefit
another way that's where again public
health people love us we're reinforcing
sensitivity and specificity
the other commenters
so I'm a licensed as a factious
inquisitions
before you know 10 years before World
graduate or 10 years ago we didn't have
any happy that I plying health records
when I started practicing we had a
computer we had to dial in to you know
get on the internet right so we are
almost illiterate IH
so what we are looking forward to is
these developments
being corporator to this job or
that that is what we are looking
and obviously we'll have the background
having that okay calculate the
Framingham's criteria for example you
got all the elements in the medical
record why can't this computer calculate
it for me why I have to go and put all
these things in when there is already in
the background in the database all these
things are available yeah exactly what
my fantasies to go to my doctor's office
not after by my interests 18 times but
so we know it's possible in some cases
there may be technical restrictions but
so much of it has to do with the work
that bill is prepared inherited
clinicians are better informed even it's
a subset about what's possible like I
always define informatics it's that is
it then intersection between what's
possible
so the intermissions understand what's
possible the engineers understand what's
possible when I was at MIT believe me
hacking in an innie ur phone bill
deleted was really cool actually I
suppose it was useful to but you know so
we need more people that can can see
that intersection and give clinicians
and I said it broadly physicians nurses
pharmacists everybody give clinicians
kind of voice into these implementations
and and we already know from literature
that implementations tend to not go
so you don't have to be you don't have
to have a masters or PhD what we're this
is where i'd love to see what actually
comes out of this in 10 years but i
think we've probably i'm hoping we have
our medical students knowledgeable
enough and empowering enough not that
they're going to go reengineer a system
that they're going to know wait a second
there's a better way to do this and then
say the engineers here's what I need can
you do this yeah sure we can do that
thank you doctor so thank you everybody
I appreciate your comment